i know that labour called for a circuit
breaker lockdown
already and so you know i know the urge
to say i told you so it's going to be
strong but you know let's try and resist
that
do you support the national knockdown
announced by the government and will you
be voting for it
everyone will have seen the increase in
infections in hospitalizations and in
deaths
that's why we did call for that circuit
breaker three weeks ago because it was
clear the numbers were heading in the
wrong direction
it's right that the government is acting
although that has come too late it's
coming too late in order to have the
full effect
that a circuit breaker would have had
but we will support the government in
putting in place measures
to save lives and to protect the uk so
you're going to be voting
for it when it comes to the house of
commons we will support it
um however it would have been better if
we'd been in a position
where the government had brought forward
that circuit breaker instead we're in a
position now where we're facing a
national lockdown
a lockdown that we don't fully
understand whether that will have
the end date that the government has set
out i heard michael gove earlier
indicate that it could well go beyond
the start of december the government has
been too slow on this they were too slow
in the initial phase of the coronavirus
crisis they've been too slow now
let's look ahead though because as i
said at the beginning you know it's easy
to criticize
what should have happened to to look
backwards but actually i think what
people care about is what is going to
happen going forward you mentioned there
michael gove indicating pretty strongly
that it could last
longer than four weeks is that the right
decision should the government be driven
by the data
or should it end on the 2nd of december
no matter what
the government should be driven by the
evidence and by the advice that they
receive and that's why it was so
disappointing
that they've ridiculed the evidence
they've ridiculed the science
and they've ridiculed they have
consistently
said that a circuit breaker with the
wrong approach have ridiculed that
approach and
instead we're ending up in a position
where we're seeing a national lockdown
potentially with no end in sight this
has been such a hard time
such a difficult period for our country
to be in this position now
will not only come at a significant cost
in terms of life
but actually is going to make the
recovery far slower and will make the
economic damage
much longer than if the government had
acted sooner inaction has had very real
consequences
for our country um you say that the
government should be driven by the data
in determining how long the lockdown
should last
and that feels a bit different from
labour's position over when you were
calling for the
circuit breaker uh lockdown and i spoke
to uh rosetta allen khan last sunday
who said that labour's circuit breaker
would last for a certain amount of time
no matter what happens and then we would
go back into the tiered system
so why have you now decided that it
should be data-driven well as soon as
kia stammer saw the evidence arising out
of sage that was advocating that circuit
breaker approach we called for it
once we saw it was clear the evidence
pointed to that of course
governments have to keep this under
review but the fact that the government
rosetta was saying last sunday she said
it would last for a certain amount of
time no matter what happens
well we'd said that it would be a short
sharp two to three week
circuit break instead what we're facing
now because of the slowness in the
government response the slowness that we
saw in march and the slowness that we're
seeing again now
we are facing a longer deeper lockdown
and that comes at a cost
you know so many jobs have been lost
already so many businesses have gone to
the wall
i mean the chancellor was going around
telling whoever would listen that he was
against a circuit breaker yet the damage
to the uk economy that will come
from the government failing to walk
sooner will be significant
and i've spoken to family businesses who
have you know faced such a tough period
they see the businesses that they've
worked hard to build up over so many
years
slipping through their fingers and those
people who haven't had any support
during this crisis that have been locked
out of government support that have
fallen between
fallen through the gaps there's been
nothing offered by way of support
for them they don't know what the future
holds it is such a worrying and
uncertain time and
i'm keen to talk about education because
unlike in the first
lockdown educational settings are going
to stay open schools
universities and yesterday kevin
courtney the general secretary of the
national
education union said it would be
self-defeating for the government to
impose a national lockdown while
ignoring the role of schools as a major
contributor to the spread of the virus
the government should include all
schools in proposals for an immediate
national lockdown what does labour think
should schools stay open
yes they should stay open of course i
understand the concerns that unions are
expressing on this
but you know i've seen the impact that
children in my community the impact
that's been felt by children in places
like sunderland and the north east
where they've been out of school for a
significant period of time they can't
afford to lose that loss of education we
can't see that
happen again they already start school
behind them or affluent peers they
already face such challenges
in getting on in life it is vital that
schools remain open but we do need to
see government putting in place support
to make sure that all teaching staff
and staff within schools have priority
access to testing how about face masks
should they be used in schools
the government should be led by the
evidence on what the best approach is
but we know we
the the impact that this will have on
children if schools were to close would
be immense
in terms of their mental health and
their long-term future prospects
schools should stay open i think there
is a different argument however around
the approach the government should
consider on universities
oh what's that then well i think the
government i think there's a different
position around universities we do need
to see
the government setting out what their
plan for the end of term looks like
and whether they could encourage
universities to move towards move away
from face-to-face teaching
okay interesting that's what you'd like
to see then well i think the argument
around
it's a very different setup where it
comes to university teaching to
school-based teaching
and i think young children do absolutely
need to be within school to be receiving
that full education
but university students could for
example move to online learning more
easily it is far more easy for older
young people to be able to do that but
we do need a plan for the end of term
too
okay um just quickly on the financial
support the government's extended the
furlough scheme for a month
do you welcome that uh how worried are
you that they haven't
guaranteed that it will be extended if
the lockdown's extended
it was mistake back in july for the
chancellor to announce that he was
starting to withdraw that support when
it was far from clear
that we were through this crisis he's
had to come back time and time again
and put in place measures to address the
fact he's had to rip up schemes
i think it is incredible that businesses
were looking to today
where we would see the introduction of
the new job support scheme only to be
told
with less than six hours notice that
instead furlough was going to be
extended
the government had months to plan to get
us to this point and instead we're
seeing last minute decisions that will
be causing real damage
to jobs and businesses we haven't also
seen support put in place around those
people who've already lost their jobs
hundreds of thousands of people in our
country have already lost their jobs and
they are not seeing support put in place
in order to get them back into work the
government needs to do a lot more on
that too
now i want to talk to you about
anti-semitism
jeremy corbyn's been suspended from the
labour party
after he said that the problems with
anti-semitism in the party had been
dramatically overstated he was of course
responding to that critical report
by the equality and human rights
watchdog and we just heard from david
miliband who said
he told the show earlier i think he put
himself beyond the pale
and it's essential that he shows that
he's willing to come within the pale
do you think that jeremy corbyn put
himself beyond the pale
jeremy corbyn's statement arising out of
the hlc report was deeply disappointing
we accept the findings of that report in
full and we will be implementing its
recommendations
the publication of that report was a
shameful day for our party
and kierstahl has apologized to jewish
communities for the harm and the pain
that we have caused
through our failure to tackle
anti-semitism but on that specific case
obviously there is a process
underway now the party's disciplinary
process and i can't really say much more
on that
at the same time what i'm struggling to
get my head around
is less than a year ago
jeremy corbyn was your party's candidate
to be prime minister you know you were
all knocking on doors telling people
that they should vote him into number 10
and now he's not fit to be a labour mp
many of us made our views known both
publicly and privately on the parties
handling of anti-semitism and on the
leadership of our party should care
stamina had done more he was in the
shadow cabinet
kias thomas spoke out both publicly and
privately as did many of us
but he supported him to be prime
minister he sat in the shadow cabinet in
one of the most senior roles alongside
jeremy corbyn kia was clear that the
party must do more to tackle this but
what are jewish
should he have done more though should
he have spoken out more should he refuse
to stay
in the shadow cabinet as other people
did some of your colleagues
refused to serve in the shadow cabinet
others refused to even be in the same
party as jeremy corbyn these were
difficult decisions for us all some of
us chose to stay on the back benches
others felt the way to change things
was from within the shadow cabinet was
but keir was absolutely clear
that the party should do more to tackle
anti-semitism but i think what matters
most now and what our jewish affiliates
within the party are telling us
is they want us to look to the future
put in place the changes
that we need to see in order to get the
party back to where it needs to be
and begin that very difficult process of
starting to earn the trust once more
of jewish people within our country who
have been so badly let down
by our failure to tackle this poison
within our midst